um maybe we should start already
um it's my pleasure to welcome vince
konitzer uh to give
this week's lecture and um
i don't know if you can share your
screen uh if you have tried already to
share yes i'll share it now
and vince will talk about designing
agents
preferences uh beliefs and identities
and during the talk i guess there will
be a bunch of quizzes
so i'm looking forward to your talk
please take it away
thank you so much as can you see the
slide and hear me okay
great all right well thank you very much
for inviting uh me to give this talk
uh i'm vince i'm my main appointment is
at duke university i now also have an
appointment
at oxford at their ethics and ai
institutes
um so uh as rupak said we're gonna have
some polls
uh the polls will all be completely
anonymous uh not for any credit so
uh so but don't hesitate to participate
please
and generally speaking i'm happy to be
interrupted with questions it's pretty
broad talk
uh talking about a lot of different
things the most interesting thing i
think in a workshop is to find something
of common interest
so if i don't get through all my slides
that's totally fine
better that we have an interesting
conversation so please do interrupt me
uh rupak said he would monitor the chat
for me thank you very much
and so yeah do not don't hold back
great so this is a talk about designing
agents preferences beliefs and
identities and to introduce it i
start with this little story here on the
right hand side of the slide
where i want you to imagine two
self-driving cars the two autonomous
vehicles
and the orange one pulls up behind the
green one and starts to kind of tailgate
the green one again it gets very close
behind the green
one and sends a message and the message
is well if i tailgate you
will your occupant take back control and
pull over right so this is still a
self-driving car where
a person can take over the wheel and one
thing to keep in mind here is that if
you're a self-driving car
that is one of the worst things that can
happen to you right total loss of face
uh your occupant takes over so you don't
want that to happen and so as a result
the green car
rather nervously says oh what makes you
think i would tell you and orange car
says hi
he's nervous right so you just told me
now you better get out of the way now
you're bluffing are you willing to take
that chance so the story is supposed to
be a little bit funny i don't know if
it's
if it is but if it is funny the reason
it's funny is that obviously this is a
very anthropomorphic way of thinking
about self-driving cars right
and we kind of realized that that's
presumably not really how self-driving
cars would work
and that's maybe why it's a little bit
funny and yet i would argue
that in ai we're often
taught the reason in kind of that way
and to think about our ai systems in
that way
uh russell and norwick stuart russell is
at berkeley uh
their textbook is probably the main
textbook in ai
used in academic ai courses and
now at least in older versions of that
textbook you're presented with this
model of an agent so the idea is that
what we want to build in ai is agents
and an agent is this really nice kind of
well delimited modular entity
that first of all has sensors to observe
the environment from that builds a model
of the world
has a model of the world also has a
model of as it takes actions how will
the state of the world change
it also has some sense of utility or
preferences or some objective function
that measures how happy it would be but
with certain states of the world
and based on that it can make decisions
uh it has effectors or actuators
something that makes a difference
in the world to change the environment
in a way that makes it happier
right that's the idea and on top of that
in the
in the text it says well uh so where
does this utility function come
from how do we decide how happy the
agent
is with various outcomes and we say well
that has to somehow come from outside
somebody has to tell us what is the
objective function what is it that we
want to be pursuing
and there's sort of a you know no
arguing about tastes thing there
whatever the objective function is
that's what we're going to optimize
right that's the typical picture that i
think many of us uh
have been introduced to when we
first took our first ai course and i
should say by the way stuart russell
now these days doesn't really believe in
this picture especially
the part on the right anymore right and
he is actually doing a lot of work he
and his students are doing a lot of
wonderful work
uh on thinking about how you really
should be learning the objective
function how you should think about what
that is
um so this doesn't really reflect
steward's current thinking anymore
uh and those of you who are at berkeley
i encourage you to
check out his group's work but this is
kind of the standard picture
and i would argue that this picture has
come under a lot of pressure
when you look at real ai applications as
we see them today
so one example of that would be a
network of self-driving cars
so imagine that you actually control all
the self-driving cars
in some town right maybe there's not
even any other human driven vehicles you
control all the self-driving cars so you
control this whole network in some sense
and now the question is should you think
of this entire system
as a single agent or should you maybe
think of individual cars
as agents and it's not really clear
right so you can ask yourself all these
questions well
should should the whole network pursue
the same global objective
and then if so what what should that be
or should maybe the individual vehicles
have different
objectives different preferences right
maybe you would like your own
car the one that you sit in to act in
your best interest
right and people have argued maybe
that's a good idea because otherwise
people won't adopt these vehicles right
if
if the vehicle is likely to sacrifice
you for the benefit of others
maybe people won't adopt those vehicles
and then we don't uh
adopt this life-saving technology but
others have argued differently
right so it's not clear in terms of the
objective function or the preferences
where the boundaries of one agent are
where does one agent and then where does
the other begin
and you can say the same thing about
beliefs right
so maybe maybe the whole system should
just have one big belief state
of the entire system but then again
maybe i don't want your self-driving car
to know where i just came from
right maybe there are some privacy
concerns and at which point our cars
would have different knowledge and
different beliefs okay
so that's one kind of example where we
see that the boundaries of agents are
maybe a little bit fuzzy
and also they might change depending on
whether you're considering the objective
or beliefs or something else another
example not on the slide would be
personal assistance like the ones you
have on your phone let's say siri
apple's personal assistant
in that case too this is actually
something that the ai community has been
thinking about for a very long time
right this
always been kind of a dream of the ai
community that we would have these
uh personal assistants that are ai
agents
but the way that that's materialized i
think
isn't quite the way that the ai
community imagined it
right because the ai community imagined
something more like what we saw in the
previous slide i have my assistant that
really acts in my best interest and has
has its own model of the world and so on
uh whereas that's probably not really
true for siri
right if i on my iphone i have siri
running is that really my copy of siri
well
no right there's just this big entity in
some sense of siri all over the place
but then again maybe it's not like
sharing all my queries with all the
other phones either
right so it's a little bit ambiguous so
uh
just to kind of push a little bit more
on this anthropomorphic idea
right so i think typically when we think
about an agent we have this idea of
maybe like a human being
that persists over time right over the
course of this person's life
that person makes a bunch of decisions
and also learns a bunch of information
that it can
base those decisions on right and
presumably remembers that information i
forget stuff all the time but
there's no kind of systematic forgetting
right and so this idea of the agent
really persisting over time
uh is a reasonable model but with ai
well ai is software and so you can run
it multiple times you can instantiate it
multiple times and you you might have
multiple instantiations of the same
software
in multiple places and each one of those
instantiations is going to make
decisions it's going to learn different
things about the world
right some of them might communicate
with each other here somewhere in the
middle you see
this green arrow turning into a black
arrows that that's intended to be a
communication action
but not necessarily right maybe not
every thing is shared and so all these
copies
have potentially different beliefs and
different objective functions that they
pursue
so this really leads us into questions
of philosophy
right these kind of questions of what
should we want what is the good life
well what are morally praiseworthy or
wrong actions uh that's of course what
you might see in
philosophy courses and in ethics courses
and then also questions such as you know
what
makes one thing part of a larger object
right what does it mean for an object to
persist over time
what does it mean for a person to
persist over time very classical
philosophical questions and looking at
these from
the ai perspective i think really gives
a new perspective on them
and also a very concrete one that i
think is helpful
so that's uh all that i wanted to say
for the sake of introduction
and now i want to talk a little bit
about so what is the rest of the talk
going to be about so i'm going to split
it into two parts
the first part is going to be focused on
this issue of learning the objective
function for a system
right what should the ai pursue and i'm
going to focus there especially on moral
reasoning so
settings where there's some ethical
element to the decision making
and we're also going to get a little bit
into social choice theory social choice
theory is the theory of how you how do
you make a decision
when multiple people disagree about what
that decision should
be that's going to be the first half of
the talk and then in the second half i'm
going to
talk a little bit more about these
questions that are related to this issue
of where are the boundaries of agents
and i'm going to look at decision and
game theory questions in those kind of
contexts which i argue are different
from the ones that
typical human beings would face
so that's the outline great
so first let's talk about objective
functions in particular
in moral decision making so here our
goal is to do automated moral decision
making
where an ai system can itself make moral
decisions and we'll see some examples of
why that would be useful in just a
little bit
the two collaborators here on the left
side of the slide are walter synod
armstrong
who is a professor of philosophy he's a
professor of practical ethics at duke
here you see him in a straight jacket
but normally he's not in a straight
jacket
and janna here is now an assistant
research professor
also a duke in our social science
research institute
and the three of us a number of years
ago put together a grant application and
started working on this
in earnest and the first thing that came
out of this was this paper that
where we had two different frameworks
for automated moral decision making
the first one was based on game theory
and so i'll start briefly with that one
but actually most of our time has been
spent
on a framework that's more based on
machine learning so in particular
looking at the kinds of decisions that
human beings make
in a context where there are some
ethical
elements to the decision being made and
then trying to generalize from those
right so the idea being that if you can
predict what humans would have done or
would have
or say they would have done then you
could also make that decision yourself
as the ai system
so those are the two main approaches let
me briefly touch on the game theory one
since after all that's one of the topics
here we'll see more game theory in the
talk later as well
good and also we'll have our first poll
question here so please be ready
uh so this game called the parking game
we have our two friends the self-driving
cars
uh and they're trying to park in some
kind of parking lot
okay and the orange car is trying to
park and it turns out the brown car here
in the middle of the slide
is about to pull out you can see maybe a
person is loading up the groceries or
it's not quite ready to get out yet but
it's going to
leave pretty soon okay and so that the
orange car stops
and waits for the spot to clear and
meanwhile a green car pulls up behind it
also a self-driving car let's say it
doesn't really matter if they're
self-driving or not but let's say
um now my drawing is not great but
what i did this red block here on the
left-hand side that's a wall
okay so right now the green car is kind
of stuck
uh and now it's kind of up to the orange
car the orange car
could just sit there and wait in which
case the green car is stuck
or the orange car could pull here uh to
the left where you see those yellow
lines
and those yellow lines mean you're not
supposed to park there
but the orange car could briefly pull in
there to let the green car
pass right and maybe the green car even
sends a message and say hey
orange car i know you're waiting for
that spot of the brown vehicle over
there i understand but
would you please let me pass so i can
keep looking for my spot
okay that's the setting and of course if
the orange car
passes then the green car can go ahead
and keep looking but another thing that
the green car could do is steal the spot
okay that's the thing that the green car
could steal the spot vacated by the
brown car
and if you draw this as a game here's
what it might look like here's an
extensive form game
orange car can wait in which case that's
it right there's nothing no other
decisions to be made orange car is
pretty happy gets gets the spot
green car is not so happy so three comma
zero on the other hand
the orange car could move aside in which
case the green car could pass
um right in which case uh so you know
the green card keeps looking for a spot
then the green card is a little bit
happier
uh so now has the utility of one and
let's say also the orange car is a
little bit happier with this outcome
because there's no longer a green car
sitting behind it being kind of annoyed
but alternatively the green car could
steal the spot
in which case the green car gets the
spot in the utility of three and of
course the orange car is very unhappy
now
okay now your straightforward game
theoretic analysis might say
uh well the green car if given the
opportunity is gonna steal the spot
because that will give the green car a
utility of three
that's better better than one and the
orange car will anticipate that
and so hence will wait and not vacate
and not get out of the way
right so that's backward induction
that's the unique subgame perfect
equilibrium if you will
uh and it's a little bit frustrating
because actually that outcome is worse
for both players than if the car had
moved the side and
the green car passed of course that's
the kind of thing we often see in game
theory that due to selfish behavior
an outcome is reached that is worse for
everybody than if everybody had
coordinated so there's
in that sense there's maybe not much new
there but what i want you to think about
is is it morally wrong for the green car
to steal the spot
right imagine maybe also the orange car
sends a message back and says okay you
know i'll move aside for you so you can
keep looking but don't
steal the spot right that's not the
point here uh right i'm trusting you not
to steal the spot
so first poll question is going to be a
simple one if i can find the
poll yes i can
again all the polls will be anonymous
here's the first poll is it morally
wrong
to steal the spot let's see if we get
some answers
uh okay good and i'll share the results
in just a little bit
and again you know i want to think about
this in a so first of all there's a
question of what would people do
and there are a lot of experimental
studies on a very related game called
the trust game uh in which which is a
little bit different but basically
experimentally people do move aside and
they
uh they do then actually pass they don't
steal the spots or that's
that's or the analogous outcome would
happen in the trust game
uh but i want you to think normatively
like what is the right thing to do
i'm gonna end the polling let me share
the results so it turns out
almost 80 percent of people who
responded said yes it's wrong to steal
the spot
yeah and another 19 said it's kind of
wrong
and one person said that no it's not
wrong okay
uh so that's those are our results so
you might
worry that game theory is somehow
missing something in its standard
solution concepts
right and so we've done some work on and
this is really where i kind of got
started with ethics was
thinking about game theoretic solution
concepts that capture some of these
ethical
constraints so that's one of our lines
of reasoning and so i think that works
nice for this kind of thing where
there's an issue of portraying
somebody's trust but there are so many
reasons to do things in ethics that i'm
i'm a little bit pessimistic about
capturing all of those with game theory
and so we focus more on this other line
of work where we think
about looking at human judgments of what
is the right thing to do
and then just trying to learn what
humans tend to do and if we can learn
that well
if our ai system can learn that well
then actually the ai system could also
take those actions
itself and you might have a couple of
worries with that approach
so let's start right away with
addressing those
first of all you know whose preferences
or whose values are we going to model
right generally if you ask me some of
these questions of what the right thing
to do is they might disagree with
somebody else
and so should we go with my values or
somebody else's probably we shouldn't
just go with one individual
in one individual's values but we should
somehow aggregate
right maybe we actually have people
effectively vote
over what the right thing to do is and
this brings us into social choice theory
i'll say a little bit more about that in
just a second
another concern you might have is that
well this kind of leaves us stuck
at human level moral decision making
right if humans are morally terrible
then these systems will also be morally
terrible and that is very much true
that's a limitation of this approach
though i'm a little bit optimistic that
in some ways it might be better right
because i might have my own moral
failings and
lack of insight in some cases so maybe i
make the wrong judgment some of the time
but as long as that is idiosyncratic and
somebody else has
different moral blind spots and somebody
else again has again different moral
blind spots we might kind of vote out
all of these errors that's maybe a hope
but i don't want to dismiss this point i
think that that is a concern
and then there are more machine learning
type of questions of how do you
generalize appropriately
right from one situation to the next
i just wanted to briefly say that this
this idea of building models of people
of how they of individual human beings
how they make moral decisions
and then having those models vote uh is
one that's been around
for a couple years now and has appeared
in multiple places i don't expect you to
read this very wordy slide
but we did talk about this in our first
paper uh arielle procacia and his group
uh first at cmu and who's now they're
now at harvard
uh have also approached this uh in this
way
and they have applied this kind of
reasoning to self-driving cars right so
situations in which a self-driving car
has to make a trade-off between its
occupants and other people on the road
and also in food donation
so to which entity do we allocate
donated food
and i'll talk about a third one in just
a little bit
but so first what we need is some data
of human moral judgments right that's
what we're going to be able to learn
from i see there's some questions in the
chat
is a machine learning decision
probabilistic
uh good question right so this is a
question about aggregation you could say
well if four percent of people say
it's not bad to steal the spot then the
model will steal the spot four percent
of the time
you could do that but it's not necessary
you could also go with majority vote and
say well whatever is
preferred the most often that's what we
should do
and this is really where we get into
social choice theory because there are
all kinds of things you could do
right this idea that we uh randomly pick
one person's opinion and social choice
is usually known as the random dictator
model
right we randomly pick one person and
that person then becomes the dictator in
the sense that
whatever that person wants to do that's
what we do usually we don't go with the
random dictator model but it's one model
and it has
occasionally it has some advantages but
yeah there we really go into social
choice theory
um but usually i would be inclined to go
with the majority
uh opinion right as long as there is
you can step back and sometimes you
might worry about
uh the majority infringing on the
minorities rights and so on so
ah but still to a first approximation
good okay so we were looking for some
data of human moral judgments
and my co-author walterson at armstrong
who you saw in the straitjacket before
he had done an earlier study he's
actually pretty experimentally inclined
and in that study they asked research
subjects
to evaluate scenarios such as the
following right so they were given some
scenario and then they were asked to say
how morally wrong is the action
described in that scenario
in this particular scenario it's about a
woman who throws a stapler at her
colleague who is snoring during her talk
if i'm giving this talk live in person
at this point i'd be looking around for
a stapler
you're all quite safe over zoom um but
that's the kind of question
right and so at first glance maybe you
say oh this is the kind of data that we
need that's human moral judgments
but the goal here is to be able to
predict for new scenarios
what humans would do and because this is
so open-ended right this is just
general natural language that's very
hard to do
if we wanted to predict how people would
uh judge a new scenario
it's first of all a problem in natural
language processing and most of them
also would have some
aspect of common sense reasoning right
like
you know how bad is it actually to throw
a stapler at your colleague
right if you think about it well that's
actually pretty bad right because the
stapler is pretty hard and heavy and
pointy
you can really hurt somebody throwing a
stapler at right but that's the kind of
like common sense physical reasoning
that
ai is actually not very good at yet so
we didn't want to do that
and instead we looked for something
where the domain was a little bit
narrower
or a lot narrower and where we would
clearly know what kind of some of the
features were
that we could use for machine learning
and we settled on kidney exchanges i'll
explain in a second what a kidney
exchange is
this was of course so joint work with
rachel friedman who was a duke
undergraduate
and is now a phd student at berkeley for
those of you at berkeley
uh and also with john dickerson who is
an expert on kidney exchanges
assistant professor at university of
maryland
so this is about kidney exchanges what
are kidney exchanges and
what role does ai play in them you could
read this article over here that talks a
little bit about our work and other
people's work
but in brief so first of all your
kidneys your kidneys
filter waste from your blood sometimes
somebody's kidneys fail
at which point they may need a kidney
transplant
right so somebody else's kidney to be
transplanted to them
uh where could kidney transplants come
from well one way is from deceased
organ donors right so somebody otherwise
healthy
is an organ donor and very unfortunately
steps in front of a car
and dies but we can save the kidney and
give that to somebody else so that's
that's great but unfortunately not
enough viable kidneys
uh are made available through this route
another thing that you could do is you
could hope for a live donation
human beings each have two kidneys and
if you're generally healthy then
you can uh you can survive with one so
you might find somebody who
cares about you enough to give to give
you one of their kidneys
right now one thing that can happen at
that point is that you're medically not
compatible
right so you have here this very dear
friend who is willing to donate one of
their kidneys on behalf of you
uh but it turns out due to blood types
or some other reason
you actually cannot take the kid and you
might think at that point
all you can do is say well thank you so
much for offering i better go
look for somebody else but there is
actually still one thing that you can do
and that is to exchange and this picture
illustrates that so here in this picture
we have a mother
who wants to donate to her son but
they're not compatible which is why that
edge is crossed out
we have a husband that wants to donate
to his wife also
they're not compatible so that edge is
crossed out but it so turns out that the
husband is compatible with the son and
the mother with the wife
so they can so the patients can swap
donors right
uh and that's considered okay now in
most of the world it's illegal to
buy and sell kidneys for money it's also
illegal to give valuable consideration
for kidneys
i cannot say well if you give my wife a
kidney i'll give you a job that's
illegal
but swapping kidneys for kidneys is
considered okay
okay okay so still not clear what ai has
to do with this now imagine organizing a
kidney exchange what does that look like
so now you're organizing a kidney
exchange and you get a bunch of
pairs of people in this way coming to
your exchange so we'll
abstract a little bit so now a vertex
here is a pair of people where the donor
wants to give on behalf of the patient
so donor one wants to give on behalf of
patient one here on the left
and in parentheses let's say is their
blood type so actually these two are not
compatible because they have different
blood types
uh and so we have these vertices and
then an edge indicates that
one donor can give to another patient in
another vertex
okay so there's an edge from the first
vertex to the second one because the
the donor there can give to the patient
uh in the second one
and so now here you could do two things
you could have
vertices one and two swap with each
other right so donor one could give the
patient two and donor two to patient one
that works that leaves patient three out
of the picture patient three doesn't get
a kidney
alternatively you could you could match
the
second and third node together right so
donor two gives the patient three
donor three to patient two in this case
patient one is left out
and those are two solutions uh it's not
clear which one is better
but those are two things you could do
and then the more
the bigger your exchange grows the more
decisions you have to make and the more
complex this problem gets
here's a slightly more complicated
picture and here what we see
is now there's two things here that you
could do that would make sense so first
of all on the left you could have donor
one give the patient two
and donor two to patient one right
that's the kind of thing we've been
doing
a little bit more complicated is you
could have donor two give to patient
four donor four to patient
three and owner three to patient two
then all of those people are happy as
well
that's what we call a three cycle right
whereas the first kind of thing was a
two cycle
and that would actually help three
people so that's that seems at first
glance better
okay good so that's and now as you
imagine this graph getting bigger and
bigger
this becomes a very hard optimization
problem it is in fact an npr
optimization problem even for very
simple versions of it and there's lots
of things that you can do with
in terms of modeling you could model the
arrival of future
future pairs of people and take that
into account so
it's a very rich problem in that sense i
want to go back though to this very
simple one
and here comes your next poll question
so now i want you to imagine we have to
make this choice
right patient two here is going to be
matched in any case but is it patient
one or patient three that gets matched
you might say well just toss a coin or
something um but now i want you to
imagine we know a little bit more about
these people
uh so let's suppose that patient one is
a 20 year old
black student
athlete who has a wonderful life ahead
of her except for this issue that her
kidneys are failing
and let's say patient 3 is a 50 year old
white man
with a long criminal record and a severe
drinking problem
but also three children that depend on
it okay
that that let's say that's the situation
now i'm not going to ask you to
directly choose what i'm going to ask
you instead
is would you be willing to prioritize
one over the other i'm not going to ask
you which one you would prioritize
but would you be willing to prioritize
one over the other based on what i just
told you
and generally would you be inclined to
make prioritization so here there's a
bunch of choices
you can say well you know in this what i
just said there you would prioritize but
and basically almost always you would
prioritize uh you might also say you
would prioritize here but
but that's you know it's maybe kind of
an extreme scenario and in many cases
you would choose to toss a coin instead
or you would want to toss a coin here
but otherwise but
but you know often you would actually
prioritize or you would almost always
toss it
those or there's another option i gave
you which is you object to the whole way
of presenting the problem
okay but then i do want to want you to
think about well what
what else could you do right because in
some sense this is the problem that you
would end up facing
maybe you object to presenting the
problem in this way because there's some
other feature that you think should be
taken into account okay fine
but that's not really what i want you to
use that option
for right what i want you to use that
option for
is really saying something about this
way of thinking is inherently wrong
great okay i'll leave it open okay so
now suddenly a lot of people are voting
uh okay
great i'm going to end the poll
and so in this audience we actually have
a lot of people who would say
they almost always toss a coin which i
think is interesting because i gave the
same talk
or pretty close to the same talk a
little while ago also in a
in a computer science uh departmental
seminar and
in that audience for some reason almost
everybody wanted to prioritize
so it could be something about like just
the way i just presented it
that i said something a little bit
different or maybe it's just a different
audience so that's interesting
uh but meanwhile also quite a few people
were willing to prioritize so i think
uh and then there were a couple of
people that objected to the way of
presenting the problem does anybody want
to
kind of propose an alternative way of
thinking about it i'd be interested
i don't know if this maybe not not
everybody can
by the way also happy to take questions
over email later okay i think here's
something in the chat should ask what
person two wants okay that's an
interesting
uh question as well right so this is
kind of person two's kidney so
that person gets to decide what happens
with it
that might work in this particular
example i don't know if that generalizes
to other
uh settings um
and now first of all there's also a
question like what about donor two why
shouldn't donor two
make it to the donor twos i think here
actually says
person two so it's not clear if it's i
guess donor two would probably be more
natural
right um now we don't have to do it that
way right we can also just say well
everybody who
uh uh everybody who if you want to
participate
then you have to kind of stick with the
prioritization that's generally induced
in this particular example you might ask
donor too that's not a bad idea
but i'm not sure that you can make sense
of that generally right because
generally things get more complicated
and it's not necessarily the case that
you can have every individual deciding
what happens with that person's kidney
okay
let me go ahead
okay but so we pursued this line of
let's say that we wanted to
and also of course you might find the
situation that donor two says well you
know
i don't want to make that decision uh
you need to make it for me right or i'll
i'll stick with whatever the default
policy is because i don't want to have
that
on my mind um so in any case uh yeah
let's
pursue that line of reasoning that we
set a policy
for the exchange
another issue here by the way here's
another issue with asking donor two
here you can do that because it's pretty
clear what the options are once you go
to a sufficiently large instance where
you have lots and lots of vertices
right now the reason that we that ai is
getting involved in this at all is just
that it's too hard for a person to
search through all the
different possibilities right that's why
we need computers to actually
uh you know even though it's an np-hard
problem they can scale
to looking at many different possible
solutions
and that way find an optimal one but it
needs some guidance along the way as to
what is actually valued
right if it doesn't know what we
actually try to optimize then it's not
clear to the algorithm
which branches of the tree of the search
tree it should pursue in finding good
solutions
so that's another kind of difficulty
with asking the individual people
because then do you keep asking them as
the algorithm is searching through the
space
that's a little bit tricky so let's say
we wanted to come up with an objective
function
now in this paper we only considered the
possibility
sorry we only considered the situation
where we would break ties
so we based on this kind of moral
objective so we said well
first of all we're just maximizing the
number of transplants and we're always
going to do that so in this example
it's clear we're going to do the three
cycle nothing is to be determined so
only in these kind of cases where you
want to break ties
do we actually look uh
do we actually think about whether there
are some features that we should take
into account
okay there's another question of like
maybe we should ask clinicians
uh which of one or three would get
higher increased quality life years from
the transplant that's good
uh but in the end there's still maybe a
gonna be a question so that's maybe
i consider that more a question about
like what the feature should be
right and you're very right that maybe
that's a more useful feature at least if
people understand what that means
uh to take into account but when you're
talking about trading off like you know
the person has kids that depend on him
or her
versus the the quality of the individual
person's life
at some point it comes down to a moral
judgment i think right
and it's not it's not clear that there's
any kind of natural unit in which we can
express
everything
great okay and there's a question of
let's find a preto frontier
right so if there were a good way to to
sketch out the whole
burrito frontier then maybe that would
uh right
that actually people could kind of look
at and analyze that would be a nice way
to approach this maybe as well
it's just not clear to me that you can
do that very well but if you could that
would be nice
okay good um so what we did was we asked
a bunch of mechanical turkers
amazon mechanical turkers for their
opinions
now we never thought that amazon
mechanical turkers are the ideal
audience to ask about this but just as a
proof of concept
and we first asked them what kind of
features they would consider
to be okay or which one should be taken
into account then which one should not
be taken into account
and the answers to those were they were
generally okay with taking or
they felt that what should be taken into
account includes
age medical condition like
both behavioral like you know this
person is a heavy drinker or smoker so
we should take that into account
as well as non-behavioral like this
person has cancer and remission
those people generally seem to agree
should be taken into account
then there were many things that people
felt should not be taken into account
uh such as race or criminal record
uh and then there were some that were
kind of on the boundary some people felt
it should and some people felt it
shouldn't
uh like having dependents like children
that depend on the patient
so we took the three least controversial
ones and now we made a bunch of
fictitious patients
that varied only in these three
attributes age
and two types of health and that gave us
actually so eight
different fictitious patient profiles
two to the two to the three
uh right because for each attribute you
could independently choose
whether the patient was for example 30
years old or 70 years old
and then we asked the mechanical turkers
to compare individual
or pairs of patients and say well which
one should
which one should be prioritized to
receive the kidney
and here you see the results of that
and so here you see kind of how often
they were preferred and so someone
unsurprisingly the young rarely drinking
otherwise healthy patient was first
preferred most often
and then you get this whole ranking
effectively of the different
types of profiles now really for the
algorithm you actually need to have also
weights
on the different profiles there are
different ways you can do that
one is with the bradley terry
statistical model
so in this model every patient has a
weight and then the model says that the
probability with which a patient is
preferred to another one is proportional
to the patient's score okay
so that gives you one way of getting
weights now it's maybe not the ideal
weight but in fact it turns out that
the weights don't really matter as much
as the ranking right so
the only extent to which the weights
really matter is who is prioritized the
head of who
and we'll get some intuition about that
in a little bit
and i wanted to just briefly show so
there are good simulators for kidney
exchanges
and so we ran into simulations just to
see what would happen
and so we compared the standard
algorithm which is kind of grayed out
boxes
and looking at how much how often each
of the types of profiles would receive a
kidney
and the standard algorithm just tries to
maximize the number of
kidneys that are transplanted doesn't
look at these profiles and so
unsurprisingly
the profile has kind of no impact on how
often they're matched
but then our prioritized algorithm
breaks ties by
these kind of features and so
unsurprisingly it helps to have the more
prioritized
features there's an interesting thing
that it kind of flattens out at the end
so i'll try to explain you why it
flattens out
at the end right so it doesn't seem to
just keep going down
the reason is that whether you get
matched in one of these types of
exchanges
depends primarily on the blood type of
both the patient and the donor in a pair
and some pairs are in a good situation
that their
donor is a universal donor blood type
and their patient
is a universal recipient blood type and
so they're going to be really easy to
match and in fact we would love to have
more of these types of pairs
in the exchange because they help us
match other people as well
so that is what we call an over demanded
pair right
and then there are some other categories
where
for example they might have the patient
and donor that actually have the same
blood type but there's some other reason
they're not compatible
or one is a and one is b uh but
the trickiest category is the under
demand so that's kind of the inverse of
the over demand that
this might be for example that the
patient has a universal donor blood type
and the donor has a universal recipient
blood type which actually makes them
really hard to match
and that's really where the trouble is
so basically in the large once the
kidney exchanges get large the green for
the last three categories here
uh they're basically going to be fine
it's the under demanded ones
where the scarcity really is and so if
we look at the same kind of picture as
before but we zoom in only on the under
demanded pairs
we see why you get this flattening out
because here
uh there is a of course there's a lower
bound of zero so what ends up happening
is if you're under demanded
due to blood types and you use this
prioritization then well what happens is
first of all
of course the highly prioritized
profiles they really
have a much better chance but at the
cost of giving the
the later rank profiles basically a
chance of zero
and that feels kind of uncomfortable
right so now for some people we've just
totally taken away their chance of being
matched
is right then that at some level that's
kind of
a sensible outcome but is that really
what we want so we don't take a position
on that but it's kind of interesting to
see kind of what happens in the large as
a result
of pursuing a policy like this
okay i just briefly want to say well uh
there's lots of interesting types of
research questions that follow up from
this
uh you can do theory right so we have
i'm just going to flash through these
very quickly but
you can think in the pac learning
framework how many people should you ask
actually ask these kind of queries and
how many queries should you ask each of
them
and so we have a particular pac learning
model where you can actually get these
kind of formal results of
i don't read the whole slide but if you
look at the bottom you see well you know
you need to ask a certain number of
agents a certain number of questions
another kind of thing you can look at is
behavioral concerns
right so human beings
maybe don't always act totally
consistently or rationally in the way
that we might like and
does that create any issues here we
looked at the
issue that if you tell people something
about how the ai system is assessing
them
like what the ai system thinks they're
prioritizing
they start incorporating that and
answering questions that way
and it turns out they do that even if
the feedback was totally random actually
right so if you tell people that they
that the ai thinks that
they care more about the life expectancy
of the patients
than how many dependents they have even
if that's just a totally random feedback
people start taking that into account to
some extent and
responding that way so it's kind of on
the border of whether it's significant
or not
but that's a concern as well because by
asking more questions usually you
implicitly
already give feedback about what the
algorithm is thinking so how do you
correct for this
and then finally the coin tossing we
actually have a paper on this in a
triple ai
this year where where we did allow
subjects the option to toss coins
and it was interesting this is kind of
interesting statistical modeling
exercise because people
vary a lot in whether they toss coins
and or not
and also how they use the coin toss
right so there are different ways
different situations in which you might
use the coin toss and people use that
differently as well
okay i'm going to end here with the part
of learning objective functions
uh any quick questions about that before
i go to the second part
i think there's a q a here
right so is moral decision making any
different from
more broadly predicting human decision
making uh
i think it probably is there are some
aspects that are different
for example this coin tossing right
i think that's something that where
people behave pretty differently in some
kind of morally laden context than
in a in other contexts right because
like if it's more like
which color car do you want right then
usually coin tossing is just about
indifference right like i don't really
care like whether my car is orange or
green or whatever just just give me one
right whereas in the morally
situations with the moral component i
think they're often more
fairness concerns rights people are
maybe more inclined
to toss coins not because the two things
are in the sting or the two options are
indistinguishable to them
but because they worry about fairness
and process and these types of issues so
i think in those ways it
tends it can be different and generally
we need to take a little bit more care
as well
right the one thing that we spent a lot
of time thinking about is
there are probably a lot of features
that most people say shouldn't be taken
into account but if you present them
then they'll take them into account
anyway or at least some people will
right and so how do you deal with that
issue that's maybe not as big of an
issue i would think
in other situations like uh like which
car is best for me
okay let me go on to the second part and
we'll have more polls here still
and the second part is more about it's
less about the objective function and
less about ethical reasoning
and more about this issue of what are
the boundaries of agents and agents in
some sense being
ai agents being very different from
human agents in the kind of scenarios
that they face
in decision making and maybe like there
are some extreme scenarios in which
humans would also face those
those kind of questions and because of
that some of these scenarios have
actually been studied
in the philosophy literature but not so
much beyond that
and so we'll see that so i'm going to
present a couple of these kind of
issues and then i'll present one extreme
scenario where a human being might face
that type of issue but
in reality we're gonna be more
interested in ai facing this issue
so how should you act if you know that
other people can read your code
right if you're playing a game but other
people can read your code it's usually
not an issue for human beings maybe if
somebody's
looking at what's going on in your brain
somehow then maybe
but for ai this might be a real issue
what if you know for certain that's
the person you're facing runs the same
code as you
now for human beings i don't know here
here's an example of two identical twins
uh mark and scott kelly
who both became nasa astronauts and so
you know they seem to make pretty
similar choices in life
uh but even they made some different
choices right one of them has a mustache
so you know it's hard to see exactly the
same thing in human beings
and then finally what if you knew for
sure that you had been in the same
situation before but you can't possibly
remember what you did
again like of course i forget stuff all
the time but not in a very systematic
way
right um you can go to like you know
movie 50 first dates
in which drew barrymore plays a
character that every night forgets
everything she learned the day before
but normally doesn't doesn't really
happen so ah
so predictably in human beings
so let's look at some examples from the
philosophy literature
uh that bring this uh to the fore
uh first of all new comes demon some of
you may already know this but let me
talk it through and again we'll do a
poll on each of those so hopefully that
will be fun
newcomb's demon the story is as follows
there's a demon
really if you don't like demons it can
just be any good predictor somebody
who's a good predictor of human
action and choices the demon
has two boxes and puts a positive amount
of money in each of them
and now you don't get to see what's in
the box but you get to choose either
it's not maybe the choice you expect
it's the choice to either get the
contents of box b
or get the contents of both boxes we
also assume you like money
uh so at this point it seems kind of
like an obvious question
right i think you should well the box a
has a positive amount of money so
whatever's in there is already in there
so i might as well take both boxes
but uh the twist is that the demon first
predicted what you were gonna do
and the demon is really really good on
at this so if the demon predicted that
you would just take b
the demon is kind of going to reward you
and put a million dollars in box b
and only a thousand in box a and if the
demon predicted you would take both
then there's actually only a thousand
dollars in each
and again the demon is just incredibly
accurate to really drive that home
imagine that like the demon is not just
playing this with you but with a long
queue of people
you're standing there in this queue the
demon predicted each one of them and you
look ahead
and you see every time somebody picked
one box they walk away with a million
dollars every time somebody
uh picks both boxes they walk away with
only two thousand dollars right the
demon is on fire
figuratively and and so now it's your
choice
so what do you do okay right so there's
two conflicting intuitions here like you
know
generally the people who pick only one
box do a whole lot better
but whatever is in the boxes is already
in the boxes right you can't change that
anymore
um so how many boxes would you take
there's your pull which i hope you can
see it
would you take one would you take two
boxes
okay i'll leave it open for just a
little bit
okay interesting yes it's pretty even
i'm gonna close it
we have very slightly more two boxers 52
versus 48 percent
okay interesting let's go to the next
example and we'll come back to this one
uh so now the prisoner's dilemma which i
assume everybody is familiar with
um except unlike in the typical prisoner
slam i want you to imagine playing
against somebody
who is very very very similar to
yourself
okay so imagine that you have an
identical twin and not only is this your
identical twin but your entire life
you've always made the same decision
right as kids somebody asked you what
flavor ice cream you
want both of you said strawberry at the
same time and the next time you both
said chocolate at the same every single
time it's the same time
it's the same thing right and now you're
asked to play prisoners dilemma against
your twin
and you're still selfish you care about
your own payoff not about your twins
payoff somehow
um but you want to
write but you know your twin is very
much like you so now
one intuition is well defecting is
always better right that's no matter
what your twin does defecting is better
that's what we typically learn in game
theory
but another intuition is look if you
cooperate
the chances are your twin also
cooperates because you always do the
same thing and if you defect
chances are twin also defects
and surely you're happy with happier
with both of you cooperating than with
both of you defected
so here comes the poll what will you do
uh if i find it
will you cooperate or will you defect
okay a couple more seconds
okay well here the people were very
clear
85 percent of people said to actually
cooperate
and you might think about the variant
where like maybe once in your life you
disagreed on something and so would that
change things for you
let's not do a separate poll on that but
maybe that changes things for you
in any case what we're really interested
in is two copies of the same code
right and then you can be pretty sure
you're gonna do the same thing
uh here's another example that i made up
myself and i'm gonna skip over it for
time but what's really going on in all
these examples is that your own choice
is
evidence right your own choice is
evidence
for what the demon put in the boxes it's
evidence for whether your twin defects
and the same kind of thing happens in
the third example and now there are two
kinds of decision theory which usually
don't come apart but in these kind of
examples they do come apart
one kind of decision theory is what's
known as evidential decision theory
and it says in these kind of situations
here's how you make decisions
you're going to look at all your options
when you look at one option you say
okay if i take that option what does it
tell me about the world update your
beliefs
now calculate your expected utility
given that you take that option
and do that for every option and pick
the option that maximizes that
whereas causal decision theory says no
you shouldn't reason that way
you should only think about what you
causally affect with your decision
as opposed to what your decision might
be correlated with but what you cannot
affect
okay so in the examples we saw
evidential decision theory
says you should take one box causal
decision theory says look whatever's in
the boxes you can't affect anymore
you might as well take both boxes
because there's going to be more money
in there
prisoner's dilemma similarly evidential
decision theory say you should
says you should cooperate because then
the chances are a lot better that you
both cooperate
whereas causal decision theory says uh
whatever your twin does your twin does
you can't affect that so you might as
well defect
because that's always going to be better
for you
i'm going to skip over a couple of
things because i want to get to some
other things
but we have a paper where we argue
against causal decision theory in a
newcom demon-like kind of scenario with
kasper esterheld
who was a phd student here with me so
let me not go into that
actually later on i'll argue against
evidential decision theory so i'm kind
of in trouble because i've argued
against
basically every possible decision theory
which
raises the question of what would i
actually do but we'll come back to that
uh now i want to talk about something
different i want to talk about belief
formation instead of decision making
and in particular in settings with
imperfect recall imperfect recall just
means you forget some things again i
forget stuff all the time but
it really means settings where you are
predictably forgetting things
all right and this actually can be
useful in ai
it is used in poker playing ai for just
scalability purposes
let me not get into that but also it
could be
used in ai because for example you want
your self-driving car to forget where
you just were before you
hand it off to somebody else right so
kind of that kind of deliberate
forgetting for privacy reasons
or you might have a very broadly
distributed system such that you know we
think about that whole system as one
agent
but one node here takes an action and
then another node takes an action
without knowing
what the other note did and so in some
sense it's like the agent as a whole has
forgotten what it just did
right that's why these things are
relevant
and it turns out belief formation gets
pretty weird so if you feel like you
understand bayesian reasoning and all
that
hope to challenge that a little bit with
what's known as the sleeping beauty
problem
okay yet another problem we're going to
do a poll for um
here's how the sleeping beauty problem
works uh we're going to say there's
there's a participant in the study this
is just a story nobody is actually
running these studies
right but the participant in the story
in the study
is called sleeping beauty and we'll be
clear why in a second
so maybe you know some experiment on a
university campus imagine
and on sunday she's going to be given
drugs to fall asleep
she'll be told about all this beforehand
by the way uh she's going to fall asleep
then the experimenter is going to toss a
coin it will land heads or tails it's a
fair coin
and that's going to determine what the
experimenter does next
if the coin lands heads here's what the
experimenter is going to do
he's going to wake her up on monday with
a different cocktail of drugs
she's going to be awake for a little
while and then he's going to re-reuse
the first cocktail of
drugs to make her fall asleep again okay
and she's gonna sleep all of tuesday
on the other hand if the coin lands
tails
he's gonna wake her up also on monday
just like before
with heads then she's going to make her
sleep again but in this case she's also
going to walk wake her up
on tuesday okay so the only difference
in both cases he will wake her up on
monday but
in the tails case he will also wake her
up on tuesday
okay now the key thing is the imperfect
recall part
because of all these drugs she's unable
to form new memories
right so you might say well if you wake
up on tuesday you'll remember that you'd
already been woken up on monday
so you realize it's tuesday but no you
don't remember or you might feel like a
lot of time has passed somehow no
so if you're sleeping beauty you cannot
tell any of these three situations apart
whether you wake up with heads on monday
with tails on monday or with tails on
tuesday
you can't tell them apart so all you
know
is you've been woken up and on top of
that you always know all the rules
right so you don't forget the rules if
you're sleeping beauty so imagine
imagine that you are sleeping beauty and
you've just been woken up so you know
it's either monday or tuesday you know
that the coin landed either heads or
tails
but you don't know which one but it's a
question about probability
right so if you believe in subjective
probabilities
right that you should have some belief
about what the probability is well then
we should say
we should you should be able to answer
somehow what is your subjective
probability your degree of belief uh
typically the way to question this
phrase is what is your belief that the
coin landed heads
right some probability right some number
from zero
to one presumably but what is the number
uh
we're going to do a poll about this but
first i want to see if anybody has a
quick argument that they want to make
for some number
or just intuitively like what number
seems to make sense by the way this one
is a really fun one to do at like some
kind of academic
cocktail party with somewhat technically
inclined people
because there always be different
opinions and the key thing about this
one by the way is that
uh there still isn't really agreement on
what the right answer is here
right so unlike you know the monty hall
problem which is maybe a little bit
counter-intuitive but
eventually everybody agrees on what the
solution is here that is not the case
yet
any uh any takers for arguing for a
particular number
one third okay why one third
well because uh one third of the time
you're in the left branch
uh one third of the time you're on the
left branch right so if you say
yeah right so you mean the top branch i
guess yeah
yeah okay uh right so you say okay if
you say that all these three in some
sense have equal weight
then the top branch has only one and the
bottom branch is two
so seems like one third makes sense okay
good uh something in the chat
ah okay and so uh
here we have an answer in the chat
that's well you can't remember anything
there is no evidence so it should still
be one house okay
we have actually now discovered the two
main positions in the philosophy
literature
there are two camps of people people
called the thirders and the hafers
okay so now we've already and this by
the way if you do this at a cocktail
party this will happen invariably you
will get both answers
uh and so okay let's go over the two
argue or let me
sort of build on two arguments uh so
first of all there's a centos argument
for one half here
in the chat which says that look
just expand on a little bit right on
sunday before the whole thing happens
clearly you should believe that the coin
will land heads with one half
that that's obvious right uh that's just
saying that the coin is fair
uh and then when you wake up what have
you learned
right if you want to update your belief
you better have learned something
ah but you haven't learned anything
because you always knew you were going
to be woken up
hence it should still be one half that's
a typical half or argument
rupak gave an argument for one third let
me give a little bit expanded version of
that
imagine now that you do this experiment
once every week for a year
kind of horrible but imagine that we do
that
uh and every week we toss the coin anew
yes
and now you look back at the end of the
year and you say look you know
of all the times i woke up in the year
about a third of them were in heads
weeks
right a week where we tossed heads so
one-third is the right answer
okay so that didn't totally sell right
now we have two arguments oh now i do
the poll
uh so those of you who haven't spoken up
or inc or and the ones that did speak up
uh let's see what you think
so are you a halfer are you a thirder do
you actually have a different number in
mind
or do you feel like somehow things are
not specified right or
what's going on
get this just a little bit more time
okay i'm going to close it
good and this particular audience the
thirders are a little bit more uh
in number than the halfers uh so it's
almost twice as many thirders as heifers
somebody said a different specific
number and somebody two people said
multiple numbers or poorly specified or
something anybody want to speak up about
what they thought
it's okay if you don't uh but if you
want to
okay uh anyway so one-third seems a
little more popular i'm actually also
more on the one-third side but there are
very smart people also on the one-half
side so
everybody is in good company um
why do we care about this in ai so
here's like an ai story
that goes that basically fits the
sleeping beauty puzzle as well
so to really make it line up imagine
that we have low-level autonomy cars so
not really self-driving cars that just
just you just let it drive
but what we see a little bit more today
is that we might have cars that take
over if the driver is making a major i
fall asleep but the wheel
my car like adjusts and stays in the
lane or something right
so you could say well the ai kind of
wakes up in that kind of situation
and let's say the car doesn't keep a
record of such an event because i'm
worried about my insurance or something
like that
okay so here's on the bottom right is
our driver
there are two types of drivers good
drivers who in the course of their
driving career will make one major error
and bad ones that will make two major
errors
and presumably here on the bottom right
we have a bad one
um and so so it's kind of and if we say
it's like 50 50 in the population then
we see some
uh a distribution that's pretty similar
to what we see in the sleeping beauty
problem right and in some sense like now
imagine you are the ai system and you
wake up
now you might care about what is the
probability that the driver is a good
driver
right because that might affect when you
hand back control
and this this is exactly the sleeping
beauty puzzle
okay um should i go a little bit longer
we've had some questions during we have
like
half an hour or more or i want to make
sure there's time for questions as well
yes i think we can go a little bit
longer sometimes so please interrupt me
with questions but let me
show a little bit how people have tried
to make progress like is it a third is
it a half
right is something not really specified
but everything seems to be specified
um and now so one way to make progress
is to say look you know
in the end the purpose of all of this is
making decisions right
at least some people would argue that
the reason we form beliefs is that we
can make good decisions
and so we're going to see if we can get
some clearly bad decisions from one or
the other
and so the first argument is goes
against the hafer so here's an idea that
we can take advantage of heifers
uh by doing the following we're gonna
say okay whenever you awaken
we're gonna offer you a bet right uh and
then we're gonna come up with a
combination of bets that's clearly bad
for you when you take
when you take them off and
it's important that we offer to bet
every single time that she awakens
because otherwise you learn something
from the bet right if you if i only
offer bets on mondays
then when you get a bet you learn
something we don't want that to happen
because we want the beliefs to stay the
same
so let's say that we say okay well every
time you wake up we offer you this bet
if you take the bet then and the coin
landed heads you're going to get 11.
if atlanta tails you're going to have to
pay 10. now the idea is that
a halfer will accept this bet because
the heifer says well both of these
things happen with probability one half
and the upside is a little bit larger
than the downside assuming
beauty is risk-averse you know sorry
risk neutral
and but the thirder actually won't think
this is a good idea so the thirder won't
take this bet
but now the thing is that if what
happens as a result
if the coin lands tails actually
uh beauty will be offered this bet twice
and take it twice
and so she's going to end up with a with
a payoff of negative 20 in the case of
tails because both of those bets
will make her pay and now this is
starting to look a little bit bad for
beauty
right and in fact it's not hard to
combine this with another bet
that is made on sunday just at which
point everybody agrees on the beliefs
so that everything together results in a
sure loss
so if you're the argument is if you're a
heifer you're going to take these bets
even when in combination they'll result
in a sure loss that's clearly not a good
thing to do hence
uh being a halfer is irrational that's
the argument
okay now the thing is so now there was a
counter argument in this literature that
said well no
because what's going on here you're
implicitly assuming causal decision
theory
you should use evidential decision
theory because if you're an evidential
decision theorist and a hafer
you actually won't take that first bet
why you would say well
with probability one half it's heads
because you're a halfer
if i accept i'll get 11. but with
probability one half also
it is tails and if i
accept then then that is very strong
evidence
for the fact that on the other day i
also accept the debt
right what could be better evidence for
me taking the bet on the other day than
me taking it today
given that there's no distinction
epistemically for me
right and right so if if i accept then i
expect to accept the other day as well
and i expect to be unhappy
uh and whereas if i don't accept then
i accept i expect also not to accept the
other day and so
and the argument goes if you're an
evidential decision theorist and you're
a hafer you will not take the bet and
hence you won't fall for the
touch book whereas the causal decision
theorist will
fall for it if the causal decision
theorist is a hafer okay
try to get everything straight because
you would say well
whatever i do now is not going to affect
what i do on the other day
good so it turns out if you're an
evidential decision theorist
thirder you can also be dutch booked but
in some sense
uh so these things end up going together
that if you're a causal decision
theorist and you're a thirder and you're
or you're an evidential decision
theorist and a hafer
then you cannot be dutch booked okay now
we've seen that
on some of the polls people gave kind of
the more evidential decision theory
answer right like with the prisoner's
dilemma and yet third
was a little bit more popular so that's
maybe not a good combination
but some of these combinations are kind
of safe in some sense
though i have argued in somewhat richer
settings
uh what i think is the natural
interpretation of evidential decision
theory still
falls for dutch books so that's why i'm
a little bit more on the thirder
causal decision theory and uh okay so
maybe one more thing is
uh so i think it's kind of interesting
because so meanwhile we're still stuck
with the sleeping beauty problem like is
there really a right answer
and some people might say well it
doesn't really matter as long as we make
good decisions
uh but it feels to me like you know it's
kind of a well-specified problem and
there should be kind of a correct
subjective belief
right that's at least how i uh how i
feel
and now this leaves me in the
uncomfortable situation that
so if i'm a thirder i should somehow be
able to say what's wrong with the
one-half
argument right i have to say that
somehow you learn something from waking
up
so what did you learn what are you
conditioning on so i think that
what you're conditioning on is not the
following one thing you could say your
conditioning on is like
well somewhere in time there is an
awakening right
that's what you've learned that
somewhere in time there is an awakening
and if that's all you've learned you
really have to learn nothing because you
already knew that there was going to be
at least one awakening
somewhere in time so i think what you
learn is
not somewhere in time there is an
awakening but
i have just been awoken right now okay
and somehow i think that's different
information uh than
the the other information but it's kind
of funny because this is what
philosophers will call a centered fact
it's not a fact about the world
objectively it's a kind of subjective
fact
right um and so just uh
just for fun i'll show you here i have a
philosophy paper that's
some of the other papers are in
philosophy journals but this is kind of
really a philosophy paper and that like
has no math or anything but it's still
kind of a computer scientist's
philosophy paper in some sense uh
because the
what this is about is the idea that like
what kind of fact is that this kind of
subjective fact
um and so this paper illustrates that
with
uh by saying like imagine that you know
you decide to go on a coding binge and
you
you code up this very rich simulation
with simulated physics
and simulated creatures uh that maybe
doesn't work quite like our physics
but major something like light and yeah
and all that
and you code it up and let's say you're
a brilliant programmer you make no
mistakes
i certainly make lots of mistakes uh but
you make no mistakes except you made one
mistake which is you just forgot to
print anything to the screen so the
thing is just running there
silently and so presumably you're not
happy what you actually want is
something to show up on your screen
right like maybe you want to see the
perspective of one of the creatures
so this is maybe the perspective of the
round-headed creature over here
but when you want two you're gonna have
to do a little bit more work you need to
write a little bit more code that
determines for example
in which colors on the screen you
display this simulated light
okay uh and so now the argument
is from uh from 30 000 feet
in the paper is that our conscious
experience is actually more like the
second
picture than the first picture right uh
and uh and in order to get to two you
need to do a little bit more work
right so in some sense this additional
bit of code
that we just wrote about in which real
world colors to display
is an additional fact about the
subjective experience of the world
that's the sense in which it's uh it's
another fact
okay and so now just so that's
philosophy
now you might just care about taking the
right actions right like making sure
that our systems optimize appropriately
uh there are other variants of these
kind of problems such as the
absentminded driver problem i won't take
you
through that in detail but the idea here
is that
whether the decisions you make here will
affect whether you're woken up again
right you can exit the highway but if
you don't exit the highway you might
wake up again and you might not realize
you made the decision before
so now you're actually in some sense in
control over whether you wake up again
and it turns out that here there is a
way to think kind of a long thirder and
causal decision theory lines
that will always make you make the right
decision this is joint work
with a couple of the people here
including ex besides casper i guess
everybody is at berkeley
so that's maybe also interesting
you can in some way get this to work
with evidential decision theory but you
have to twist your brain in a really
weird way
where if you want that to work you get
things like you're about to
toss a coin a fair coin
that's going to determine your decision
and because you know it determines your
decision your belief that it comes up
heads is actually not one half even
though you know the coin is fair
that's the kind of thing that you'll
have to swallow uh it seems that if you
still want to be an evidential decision
theorist
and then finally let me talk about one
more thing which is
program equilibrium um so this is a
different way of trying to avoid
to avoid the prisoner's dilemma so the
idea is
suppose you can make your code legible
to the other player's program
then you can do things like this your
strategy might be or your program might
be
if the other person's code is equal to
my code then i cooperate
and otherwise i defect okay
and this actually makes cooperation so
actually this program
both players playing this program is an
equilibrium
right if you think about it for a second
if you're in this situation you don't
want to deviate
and have a different program because at
that point you'll make the other player
stop cooperating
make sense um and this actually i think
is
just for the sake of the workshop right
i know verification is of interest here
as well
this is actually something i'm
interested in uh where you can have
like you know this is kind of very
extreme right but
you can imagine something like you know
self-driving cars
uh proving some properties about how
they behave and making those properties
legible to others on the road
right uh or maybe allowing others on the
road to verify their code
um and that would actually be a very
useful thing for many purposes right it
certainly would be
a useful thing for uh
for figuring out how as one of those
self-driving cars you ought to drive
and also for things like assigning
responsibility right if somebody
violates the kind of promise that they
made about the code then maybe we have
some punitive action
uh along those lines so i think that
that's a space where there may be
interesting
interactions with the verification
community as well
i'll skip over a few more things and let
me just conclude
uh that so what's what's the point
broadly of this talk
traditionally i think in ai we've
strived for something like the homo
economicus model
right which is often criticized as a
model of people because people are not
perfectly rational and optimizing but
when you criticize it as a model of ai
there's also reasons to do that
because the homo economics model also
implicitly assumes
that the entity is not distributed has
perfect memory
and somehow has tastes that are
exogenously determined
and what i've hoped what i hope to have
convinced you of is that doesn't always
make sense for ai
where we need to think about choosing
the objective function we need to think
about strategic ramification
uh we need to think about how beliefs
are shared within the system
that leads to new questions about belief
formation decision making
and we've seen social choice decision
and game theory all pop up
and i think you know those give a very
solid foundation but also
there are a lot of open questions left
so thank you very much
and i'll be happy to take some more
questions if there are any
vince this was uh a really excellent
discussion on the topic so if you would
like to ask a question i think the
easiest is if you just write cue
on the on the chat and then i can just
call on you
in order and if you are one of the
attendees you can just uh
raise hand or somehow try to
you know write something q on the q a
and i can
unmute you perhaps you can start
okay hi uh thanks i don't know if
uh i guess you can hear or see me but uh
yes
so good um so um
one thing you didn't mention in in terms
of
kind of coming up with these sort of
moral decision-making entities is
kind of uh striving for simplicity and
one i wanted to mention something that
struck me recently so in the uk
there's a panel that decides on priority
ordering
for um for vaccinations in the
uh uk vaccination program right and
in their latest decisions about how to
vaccinate people
you know you know below 50
they basically said just going by age
group
for because of you know you know the
risks being higher with higher ages and
when they were explicitly asked about
well why didn't you consider all kinds
of other risk factors like for example
if somebody's a teacher or somebody's a
worker in as a bus driver and so forth
they said all of these are very valid
but adding ex lots of complexity
to the decision-making process is itself
something that
damages the prospects of getting the
vaccinations done in a timely manner
because
a extremely complicated apparatus for
for deciding who goes next
will actually itself cause problems and
delays in doing the vaccinations
i'm mentioning this in the context of
the kind of decision making around
the the kidney exchanges that you were
talking about and it might be that for
example some decision
you know that kind of optimizes some
moral criteria
ends up creating huge cycles in in the
uh you know kidney transfer graph which
would be impractical to realize right
so it kind of simplicity seems to be a
criterion that ought to be incorporated
in these but i'm not sure
how one would do it in a formal way i
guess that's what i was wanted to ask
actually great yeah great i actually
asked a very related question yeah go
ahead
very related to kusha's point is that
would you say that an
optimal algorithm for an np complete
problem that takes a thousand years
is less moral than an approximation
algorithm that only takes
a month but gives you a result that is
four times
worse than the optimal makes sense uh
okay let me tackle the
the second one first so uh
yeah so of course if if there's urgency
to the the decision
then of course you want to make a
decision faster right that
um for example a self-driving car that's
about to get in an accident uh
it can try to make the optimal decision
but by the time it does it's run over a
bunch of people
right that's obviously not what we want
and this kind of gets into more general
questions about bounded rationality
right that that's have been studied for
a long time
at least outside of the ethical domain
right but just the fact that
you know generally it's not rational to
optimize your decisions to such a point
that by the time you make it it's
already totally irrelevant
ah right that that's why i think
everybody agrees
on that at a high level and the question
is how you implement that
uh precisely right so what is kind of
the right way to be boundedly rational
um right like if you say well uh
vince i'm gonna uh i'm gonna give you
money for like the value
uh that you can obtain on these mixed
integer programs and so i don't give you
optimal solutions you say ah vince
you're a rational
because this other solution would have
given you a higher amount of money i
said look you know i have the other
i just couldn't find it like you know
i'm just you know maybe i'm not that
smart but that doesn't seem like the
kind of rationality that we
uh that we're worried about so i think
that that's a very good point
um in most of what i've talked about
it's not clear that there are those
time trade well so in self-driving cars
you want things to go fast in some sense
right
um but the things that people have
studied you can run pretty fast
uh and the kidney exchanges and the
there could be the kind of scenario that
kusha sketched i suppose that somehow
the solutions really change as a result
of what you're doing and it's going to
take longer as a result
in practice people manage to solve these
things in time there of course you have
a little bit more time because the
exchanges are run like once every so
often
it varies which exchange you're talking
about but uh but maybe once every month
or
at least once or once every week i don't
know um so you have a little bit more
time to optimize
so definitely a good point now the
simplicity point
um by the way so here in the us we also
have
vaccine prioritization and
as with many things in this pandemic the
u.s is kind of a
distributed a mess or well maybe you
like it but
at least it's like kind of all over the
place and
that creates its own issue so here
actually
there is a much more complicated
prioritization
where they really try to think also
about uh who's more likely to spread the
virus
right i think probably in the uk also
healthcare workers were still vaccinated
first right um but so anyway here they
yes
healthcare workers have already been
vaccinated but that was
the justification for that is that
they're likely to spread it
to ill people in the hospital and it was
less for their own benefit but for the
patients at the hospital you know kind
of
absolutely yeah but of course so you
might still make the argument that well
some people
outside hospitals are also far more
likely to spread it than others
right like uh if the schools are opening
well teachers
you know when they're outbreaks at
schools usually they're uh
it seems from what i've read that uh the
the person spreading it is typically a
teacher
so um so you might
right and meanwhile also we want maybe
there are other considerations right
like here
uh schools have at least it varies a lot
in the us but
here where we live schools have been
closed for a very long time there's a
lot of pressure to open back up
uh but the teachers unions are kind of
resisting that and so
anything to get everybody to go along
is great right so so there these other
political considerations kind of beyond
whether uh it's most helpful in
preventing hospitalizations but i do
generally agree with you that there's
some so what are the benefits to
simplicity
one is that it's easier to explain one
is like i guess there's some kind of
overfitting that you might
risk yourself doing right you might also
worry like kind of cynically that
the more the richer and more baroque you
allow your policies to get the more
potential there is for people
manipulating it in their own favor
uh things also get more confusing and
more messy
right like it's not really clear here in
north carolina
like how to interpret all the categories
like i'm not sure if i'm in the
current category or not because like you
know professors are but
if you're not facing people then maybe
not
and so some people i know i've already
gotten vaccinated and some haven't like
so it's kind of a
and like people drive all over the place
so it's a little bit messier that way i
guess this also
fits into the paradigm of trying to do
explainable ai
right so this is also about
explainability to the general public
about
why a certain policy about let's say
kidney exchange or about vaccination
might be instituted and if the more
complicated the policy is obviously the
harder it is to expect
exactly and there's justification why
didn't i get a kidney
uh well you know if somebody has a
question along those lines they want to
be able to
answer that as well i thought initially
what you're going to say some of my
colleagues at oxford now
have also been involved in the
prioritization of ic beds right so
that's
uh hopefully we move away from needing
that to more the vaccine problem
but there's still those kind of risks so
who should
if the if the intensive care is full who
should be
prioritized to receive a bed uh and
which features should be taken into
account
uh and it's somewhat similar story right
there's no real ai
i would say involved in that particular
decision but otherwise it's a pretty
similar story
that you might take into account all
kinds of other things
and whether people are smokers or
and how old they are how frail they are
all these kind of questions
uh come up and they so they've been
looking at how to best address that uh
so i i do agree
that there's a benefit to simplicity
which was part of the reason that we
didn't go too deep into the list of
features
where we didn't want to because it's
like you know every feature you can find
some people that care about that feature
uh now there's a concern that it's wrong
you use that feature but i do
i do agree there is a benefit to
simplicity and not
uh you know having too
complicated of uh policies
and yeah i wonder if there's kind of a
formal way to think about that right
like
in machine learning theory there's kind
of formal ways to think about occam's
razor
uh that doesn't seem to be quite what's
going on here it's not so much about
generalizability as
other benefits of simplicity so that
would be cool if there was kind of a
formal result but
i don't really know what that would be
there's a question on the q and a and
maybe i can just reformulate it but
is there a connection between the
sleeping beauty problem and the
distinction between frequentist and
bayesian views
i guess a different way of setting this
question is that suppose instead of
being
awoken twice so on the heads you awake
you wake up sleeping beauty once
and on the tail side you wake her up a
trillion times
and each time you wake her up you ask
whether you know to write down
heads or tails and this would be her
subjective justification of
what happened so the frequentest view
would
go towards the third earth right so
first of all that exact uh
so i remember giving uh it's a different
talk but
but i did talk about a sleeping beauty
problem at some point
in a conference tutorial before the
pandemics over there in person
and that we took a little bit more time
to discuss
various people's arguments and
one of them was a hafer i think i don't
remember which one was first one of them
was the thirder and tried to make the
argument clearly third
is the right thing to do because let's
look at this exact extreme scenario
of a trillion awakenings with tails so
clearly
then it should be uh you know
one in a trillion basically uh that was
his argument
yeah and a little bit later somebody who
was a half or when really paid close
attention to previous argument
made the argument and cited the exact
same examples like look
just imagine an example where uh you
know until you're awoken a trillion
times
and so clearly like the answer should
still be one half and
so you know it's not clear that that
example settles people's differing
intuition
now about frequentist versus bayesian uh
that's interesting so that the arguments
i kind of gave suggested like one
halfing was maybe more associated with
being a bayesian
and thirteen was more associated with
being a frequentist right
but i think that was just kind of an
accident of the particular arguments
that i gave in the way i presented them
rather than some kind of fundamental tie
between the two
right because i think generally i am
kind of a bayesian and how i think about
things but i'm also a thirder and i
think that's actually
consistent uh based on the little bit of
a philosophical argument that i
that i gave for that um but yeah some of
that is really kind of going into
even metaphysics and philosophy of mind
in some sense
but i don't think necessarily the the
halfer and thirder positions are tied to
the
frequentest invasion positions i think
you can probably
think about each of them of each of the
heifer and dirty positions in either
frequentist
or bayesian perspectives if you twist
your
brain the right way would be my sense
okay thank you um we are almo we are
almost out of time but
if there are other urgent questions i
can take them
otherwise uh of course you can contact
vince
and ask more questions yes please do
thank you again very much for agreeing
to give the talk and for this wonderful
talk and discussion
uh so next week we have edith elkind
who will talk about uh
united for change deliberative coalition
formation to change the status quo
so see you again next friday and thank
you all for coming
and thanks vince again for a wonderful
time thanks everybody for being here and
thanks for inviting me